Thanks to Lenovo for sponsoring this video
I Talked to Sam this morning. He said: "Jake",
"You know what'd be great? If i had a lightsaber in my life."
Well guess what. They brought em down here
Hooked us up, we got Jedi Challenges
We're gonna play. It's gonna be great
Lenovo and Disney made
Made this product called Jedi challenges
(Sam): Augmented reality game
You hold the lightsaber hilt and the screen tracks the environment,
projects lightsaber blade out into the environment
where you get to hold it and see it in front of your very own eyes
(Niko): Sam once spent 3 months doing lightsaber effects.
(Sam): That's not that long in the grand scheme of things,
But when you're 14 that's like a serious. That's like 5% of your life span
(Niko): And he did them all in photoshop, frame-by-frame
If you get hit with the lightsaber in the game does that hurt?
This is the tracking beacon, you put it in the middle
And this is basically what the AR headset uses to track the figures that you fight against
Look when I go to parties I just carry this with me.
I'm like ✌
Wren: Can i keep the bag?
*Everyone Whoos*
Wait, how much is this??
$199.99
Its an AR headset, augmenten reality
Alright, alright, here we go.
Begin
Okay
I'm spinning it. Throwing with a spin
Wren: *lightsaber noises*
Quick, they are shooting me
Thank you all right, so actually I died
The thing is while he was out spinning and chopping them up.
I was getting shot.
Just getting "blegh"
I'm gonna not do that this time,
Can I be , eum I'm gonna go on a different planet boys.
Dude, I'm gonna fight some snipers now
Alright, here we go.
They're on like speeder bikes
hey!
NICE!
Oh dude, i chopped this
Who are you facing this time?
I don't know, i think this is some prequel bizz.
Alright here we go.
Whoop, ah perfect.
You litteraly chop their head off.
They just go like *boop* and their little droid head explodes
Dang, oh you like straight-up shut them up
Chop his legg of
Oh yep, o my god. yeah
He's just like , ooh
I loved being able to chop
Dude this is great, it's like you're like like a sushi chef
I win
That was fun, fighting Jedi's and droids, but there's only one thing to do now.
Take it to the next level
okay, now I'm in the galaxy
We have a baby wookie in the projection zone here
Awh dude, it's Darth Maul
Awh, I can get closer to him
Look at this.
I'm right up in your face Darth ... Maul
Wren's gonna attempt to fight Darth Vader on top of a wheel
I can do it, I'm gonne defeat Vader
we're reenacting the scene from Revenge of the Sith
where they're floating on the lava and fighting each other.
Exactlty
I have the high ground!
You underestimate my power
You gotta know that that's super hypocritical
Cause when he was fighting Darth Maul
Darth Maul had the high ground. CLEARLY
But he still beat him.
Superb Deflection
You lose balance on the wheel or if he kills you, you lose
Really?
If you fall off the wheel it's a hambone wren.
What no work for disabling the hambone rule for this game.
Nick: No its doubled
Oh dude i'm mace Windu
i got a purple lightsaber
I landed
I could breathe under leva
Okay
Vader: Time to face your fears
Wren : *lightsaber noise*
O he died
No, no
no
I managed to not feel off the wheel though
No hambone
No hambones though, you still owe like 20 bucks
Alright there's another game type Nico's really eager to try it it's called strategic combat
Alright here we go, I got my rebel base here.
Blowing on guys up, we have some leaders here rally troops.
There we go strikesquad all right cool
Unlike placing troops on the ground
We defend these towers blow up that ATSC
There we go
Put another heavy here
Let's take some of this round
More troops, more troops
this is a sick battle, it's kind of cool. It's all tracked here
Wren: I'll break down your building Nico!
No god, wren!
Jake: Wren get outta there!
Add some troops.
More troops
Rally the troops
Rebel base defended unlike all those
fools at Hoth, I did my job correctly
You know there was actually there's like a Sabine Wren in there like yeah, it's like your sister or something
or your daughter
Wren: Kylo ren has a sister?
That means
Wait, did we just discover something about the star wars universe?
What you doing there buddy
Oh what up dude
Euhm
You've been here all night
What what time is it?
Seven in the morning.
Oh shoot!
I didn't really get to participate in the Jedi challenge, so it looked really cool
So I figured I just I don't know I thought I was just staying late after work
And uh figured I'd check out some holo-chess.
Is it really 7:00 in the morning?
7 in the morning man.
Oh well
I'm kind of like killing it at this chess game. I think I got really good at it
This game is really addictive
Once again thanks to Lenovo for inviting us to try out this device and for bringing the Jedi experience to life like never before.
Remember It's an AR smartphone powered piece of technology meaning that there are more updates to come if you guys are interested in checking it out
Go to jedichallenges.com to find out more. Have fun. Thank you for watching
Carmichael be safe man. Be safe now